[Música]
cuba y estados unidos reanudaron en
washington las negociaciones sobre
migración interrumpidas desde el año
2018 en el primer encuentro bilateral de
alto nivel desde que joe biden llegó a
la casa blanca y luego de cuatro años
detenciones durante el gobierno de
tornas trump según la oficina de aduanas
de eeuu desde octubre de 2021 hasta
marzo 2022 más de 78 mil cubanos
entraron al país por la frontera con
mexico es decir el doble de los que
abandonaron la isla durante la llamada
crisis de los balseros estos 1994 además
los servicios migratorios suspendidos
desde el año 2017 como la visión de
visados se reanudaron desde abril en la
embajada de eeuu en la habana para
analizar entonces todo esto este estos
nuevos contactos entre la habana y
washington quiero saludar en este
momento a sergio ángeles él es profesor
asociado de la universidad cerca
arboleda e investigador principal del
programa cuba gracias profesor por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 como a leer entonces este
encuentro de alto nivel entre google
washington
raúl buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación no hay que olvidar que el
resultado natural de esta nueva ola
migratoria es producto de la apertura de
fronteras desde noviembre del año 2021
desde entonces hemos tenido una salida
masiva de cubanos como se planteaba en
la nota anteriormente cerca de 48 mil 47
mil cubanos han llegado a la frontera de
eeuu y de esos tuvieron el pico más alto
en febrero de este año con cerca de 16
mil cubanos intentando entrar a la isla
acá hay que señalar que en ocasiones
anteriores en al menos 5 oleadas previas
estas crisis migratorias han conducido a
la necesidad de negociar algún tipo de
salida entre eeuu y cuba en este orden
de ideas la forma natural que tenía el
gobierno de joe biden para negociar algo
relacionado con esta crisis tenía que
ver con volver a esas negociaciones que
se suspendieron durante el gobierno de
donald trump en el año 2018 en este
orden de ideas básicamente esto es
producido por
la situación al interior del cubo que no
solamente tiene que ver con la pandemia
que ocasionó graves crisis en todos los
países de américa latina sino
fundamentalmente con las decisiones
tomadas por el gobierno de miguel díaz
canel orientadas a intentar solucionar
la crisis económica y que terminaron
agravando esta es esta situación una de
las razones principales tienen que ver
con la unificación monetaria de enero
del año 2021 y también la persecución
que se dio a aquellas personas que
participaron en las manifestaciones de
julio de 2021 claro y en este orden días
entonces por lo que hoy acaba de decir
sergio el tema migratorio por esta razón
fue elegido entre ambos países para
iniciar este contacto bilateral va a
cambiar algo que está pasando con la
migración irregular entonces de los
cubanos hacia eeuu digamos va a
incrementar y luego de estas
conversaciones puede que se pueda mermar
o incluso este número disminuir un poco
pues bueno hay que tener en cuenta que
uno de los factores que disparan esta
situación tiene que ver con el hecho de
que el gobierno cubano se ha rehusado
desde octubre del año 2021 a recibir a
las personas que vienen deportadas desde
eeuu en este orden de ideas si han
llegado cerca de 47.000 cubanos a la
frontera con eeuu y el gobierno cubano
se rehúsa a recibir a sus connacionales
pues esto agrava aún más la situación
que impresiona al gobierno a eeuu a
tomar algún tipo de decisión orientada
precisamente hacia allá no hay que
olvidar también que precisamente desde
el año 2018 uno de los acuerdos que se
han tenido antes durante el gobierno de
barack obama en términos de estos
acercamientos era que desde la desde el
consulado y desde que está dentro del
cubo del consulado de perdón en la
embajada de eeuu en cuba se iban a
emitir cerca de 20.000 visados para
cubanos dentro de la isla esto se ha
pronunciado precisamente desde el
ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
cuba en donde se manifiesta que lo que
se ha promovido es una forma irregular
de migración cuando se podría solucionar
esto si de una u otra forma que eeuu
cambiar no hay que olvidar también eeuu
retiro a parte de sus funcionarios de la
embajada desde el llamado síndrome de la
habana claro también empecé a estos
encuentros la atención sigue evidente no
y cuba acusó a estados unidos de querer
excluir luego de la cumbre de las
américas
las relaciones podrían llegar a un punto
normal si se quiere decir en un futuro
cercano en un corto mediano plazo
es difícil prever lo creo que será un
factor determinante en el momento en el
que salga la invitación esta semana
también se conoció que todavía que el
gobierno de joe biden notificó que hasta
la fecha no han salido ninguna
invitación para los jefes de estado para
el la cumbre de las américas en ese
orden de ideas todavía no hay certezas
de si efectivamente no solamente cuba
sino también nicaragua y venezuela serán
invitados no obstante desde la casa
blanca se ve anunciado desde el mes de
enero que solamente serían invitados
personas
aquellas personas y aquellos países que
hubiesen elegido democráticamente a sus
gobernantes porque este será un factor
determinante para ver si éstos estas
negociaciones solamente corresponden a
una forma de eliminar esta gran presión
que se está generando en las fronteras
de eeuu producto de esta migración
irregular y es solamente como lo
manifiesto también en la casa blanca una
forma de negociación bilateral o si
efectivamente se pensara en un algo más
allá producto de estos primeros
acercamientos lo cierto es que el exilio
cubano ya está muy molesto con este tipo
de acercamientos y marco rubio ya se ha
manifestado en contra hablando
precisamente de esos precedentes de olas
migratorias anteriores cuál es el plan
del presidente joe bayern o cuál sería
el plan del presidente yo vayan de aquí
a que se acabe su mandato recordemos que
también en su campaña para esta elección
presidencial donde donde ganó él dijo
que iba a cambiar estas políticas hacia
cuba que las iba a mejorar que tanto
además ha cambiado hagamos un balance de
estos años de gobierno de bailén en
cuanto a cuba que parece que las cosas
no han cambiado mucho no sergio
sin duda se ha tenido una se ha
mantenido una continuidad respecto a lo
que se había venido desarrollando
durante la administración de donald
trump básicamente durante la
administración de donald trump es uno de
los asuntos que quizá más afectó
directamente a cubo y particularmente al
régimen cubano fue la aplicación de el
título 3 de la ley helms burton que
permite precisamente la demanda de
empresas extranjeras que hagan algún
tipo de acercamiento en términos de
negociación con el régimen cubano esto
que ocasionó las el cierre por ejemplo
de las oficinas de western y unión
afectando directamente a los cubanos que
no podían recibir sus remesas pero
también por ejemplo en términos de los
diferentes vuelos que podían llegar
también eeuu y las mismas remesas que
llegaban hacia allí en ese orden de
ideas
esta decisión que básicamente respondía
a una firma que hacían los presidentes
de eeuu cada seis meses para suspender
ese título 3 pues tampoco ha tenido
ningún tipo de transformación no hay
ningún tipo de acercamiento también
ahora bien también hay que tener algo en
cuenta y es que si bien el gobierno de
joe biden no demócrata e históricamente
estas ollas de presión migratorias han
sido
orientadas otra o tranquilizadas de
alguna manera por estos gobiernos
demócratas joe biden ha tenido
precisamente durante su administración
el llamado 11-j en cuba que es uno de
los picos más altos de represión y que
ha generado una transformación muy
directa en términos de sus posibles
acercamientos producto de la persecución
a varias de las personas que
manifestaron dentro de este que
participaron dentro de estas
manifestaciones
sergio gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24
lamentablemente se nos acaba el tiempo
para seguir analizando todas estas
relaciones bilaterales entre eeuu y cuba
que por supuesto hay muchísimo de que
hablar sobre estos dos países y las
relaciones e históricas que han tenido y
sobre todo pues de estos últimos o
cuatro años de políticas de una tromba
ahora que ha cambiado con el gobierno yo
vaya que como lo dijimos pues no ha
cambiado mucho vamos a ver entonces si
esto sigue así o en efecto va a cambiar
sergio muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros nuevamente un abrazo
gracias